foreign
contacted us a couple weeks ago and said
there's a article in the hill uh showing
that uh up to 50 percent of American
families are paying their adult
children's bills
to a tune of an average of fourteen
hundred and eighty two dollars a month
wow
and
um
the
and the vast majority I forget what the
number was no it's up to 25 percent of
Millennials their parents are paying
their housing meaning they're paying
their house payment their rent or
they're living in their basement I don't
know which
um this is
um
I've never seen it like this
the the and and it's and so I did an
op-ed that's on the on the front page of
Fox Web right now on Fox Business web uh
on this subject and it blew up the op-ed
blew up
um just like this I mean I had a thing
on social media last week that got 32
million views it blew my mind it blew up
just and it was a clip from a couple of
years ago of me taking a call from uh
these people that were almost a million
dollars in debt and only 200 000 of it
was their mortgage I mean they were just
it was amazing and I was I don't know
why the thing blew up it's calls we take
care all the time I really couldn't see
anything different but something was
special on Tick Tock and it just went
nuts so I guess that Tick Tock
generation just had never seen they've
not seen that seen someone actually know
the answer to the question and care
deeply about the people on the other
side care enough to tell them the truth
yeah and we tell them the truth tell you
the truth here sometimes you don't like
it but we always tell you the truth but
this this thing of parents you and I
have been talking about this a lot in
America right now with a labor crisis
we're going to talk about it more on May
the 4th with this thing with Mike Rowe
that we're doing uh and you guys ought
to sign up and watch that uh uh live
stream that we're doing because this
labor crisis is tied into this loss Mike
Row a dirty jobs and I were talking this
loss of work ethic
we've forgotten how to do hard things
that's right yeah there's two houses or
a thing of the past yeah yeah there's
two things that I think parents have
eliminated over the last few decades
hard things and scary things hard things
where it's not scary it's just really
really hard I'll give you an example my
father first job I got I was 14. he went
and got the job he knew I needed to work
and he made a couple connections but he
specifically chose a job that he told me
years later he goes I wanted you to
taste really brutally hard work and I
had to go up on a ladder day for a local
painter that he knew and I had to scrape
paint off the side of a house with a
propane tank in one hand and a scraper
in the other and you know I'm 14 my arms
were as big a round of strings and
you're just it's painful it was
exhausting work and he told me I wanted
you to taste hard work so number one you
could do it number two that you would
set your sights on something higher
that's a hard thing and scary things are
allowing kids to fail to try an
instrument Dave to to to to maybe try a
small business to try a sport to do so
they actually keep score yes and you
don't get a trophy unless you win yeah
well that's a whole nother issue it's
part it's part of the problem yes part
of the problem oh yeah it's it's a big
issue
psychologists call when you pay your
kids bills psychologists call that
enabling yeah okay yeah and the rest of
us call it stupid
and you're not helping you're not
helping no because the the Little Eagles
are not gonna soar unless you kick their
butt out of the nest
no eagle ever flew with the nest
attached that's right never happened so
the helicopter parenting uh the
participation trophies I don't want my
child to ever hear or see or experience
anything negative it's not good for you
no we've got we've stunted it it's
enough good for you need to experience
uh winning yep and you winning is not as
fun unless you have also failed yeah
well you don't appreciate Wayne until
you've lost the sting of loss is what
drives Champions and and you're right
Dave this participation stuff we we've
laughed about it for decades and now
it's playing out in the workplace here's
how it's it's unrealistic and unmet
expectations this is what it looks like
in the workforce right now and it is
these kids have gotten trophies and
parties just for showing you know what's
weird is that it's not all of them not
all so they get thrown under the bus
like gen Z and Millennials get thrown
under the buses all being this and
they're not because I got 400 of them
working in the building here that are
missional they're hard working they care
deeply they're passionate they'll charge
the gates of hell with a water pistol
man but then you know they got their
friend over here who's mommy's
helicopter and the irony of irony you
know your 28 year old son lives in your
basement and in an act of sheer irony
spends his day playing Call of Duty
yeah that's something about the irony of
that yes he doesn't even understand you
know what duty is and he's never
answered a call yeah oh my God and this
is what plays into this Dave is that now
parents feel bad because their kids are
struggling and so now they pay their
bills for them industry of work Michael
Easter talks about this in the comfort
crisis we have worked very very hard
to
become to be comfortable oh yeah and
then we've worked even harder to make
sure our kids don't experience any pain
and it turns out now the data is in
that's a mistake yeah
allow your kids encourage your kids
force your kids to do hard things and
scary things that's right it is so it
get you know stand on your own two feet
there is so much dignity in that
when you have to buy your own bread and
pay your own light bill
because Mommy isn't going to do it you
have become a man my son
oh my gosh and then when you wonder why
there's a manhood crisis yeah you know
we wonder why there's a stunted growth
out there and you know it's society's
fault you know I'm triggered
kiss my butt you're triggered get off
your tail and go do something triggered
yeah give me a break see that's that's
the problem we create terms like that to
describe real emotions that everybody's
a safe space ain't no you don't ain't
one Heaven that's it right that's a safe
space until you get there yeah not gonna
be saved by that the truth accept it and
get on with it yeah you know I can't
have a car that doesn't have 73 airbags
I mean you're telling this to a
generation used to sleep in the back
window while they were driving down the
road we didn't have bike helmets or
elbow pads you know what it made us
better bike riders because if you
wrecked you stuck to the sheets for six
nights those are consequences well it's
gross Dave but it hurts try pulling the
sheet off of your leg Yeah I know
this is very exciting folks it's a rare
moment in the show hey I went farther
than Dave but you know the point is is
that we here's what happened it's a
marketing message that scared everybody
marketing started figuring out that if I
scare parents they'll buy more stuff and
then it took hold well we've got the
most scared Society it comes
from I want good things for my kids
enablers are always the nicest people
right they don't want their kids to hurt
they don't want anyone whoever it is
they're enabling they don't want them to
feel any pain and the sad thing is what
we're discovering now is is that I
controlled reasonable level of pain in
order to create growth is the right way
muscle is not built unless you get sore
how do you get sore that's called pain
working out you lift a weight and your
muscle gets sore lactic acid gets kicks
in but no muscle is built sitting it's
true it doesn't it never has happened
and the muscles of our brains the
calluses on our brains come from
enduring persevering through hard things
that's right stressful things and coming
out the other side and no one's saying
oh here's a safe space I'm sorry you're
triggered that's exactly right now what
you are is you're prepared you're
prepared for whatever life there's a
toughening because you've come through
challenges before you've done hard
things you've overcome scary things and
now you go okay I can take the next hard
thing on I can take the next scary isn't
it interesting that throughout history
that to go from adolescence to adulthood
with every culture but ours there has
been some kind of ritualistic rite of
passage that involves something hard
it's a very good point yes absolutely if
you look at I'm not saying your kid
needs to be put out there in a life or
death situation in order to be okay I'm
just saying maybe they should sweat once
at least at least think there's a bear
that's going to get them at least you
should
at least you should have a callous from
having persevered through a loss and
turned it into a win yeah and and moms
and dads in America doing this for
people you love is an act of love it's
not a big old meaning as a matter of
fact enabling is quite the opposite of
loving